c'est une ancienne base militaire
soviétique
trois heures de route de la frontière
russe ici ce sont les quelques 500
militaires canadiens qui dirige la
mission appuyés par des soldats de neuf
autres pays
le premier militaires ont été déployés
en 2017 quelques années après l'annexion
de la crimée frédéric tremblay où il ya
mme lebel deux soldats originaires de la
région de québec sont arrivés ici en
décembre avant que vladimir poutine ne
lance son évasion en ukraine ici aussi
on se prépare en cas d' attaques russes
même si williams n'est pas très craintif
malgré cette confiance frédéric reçoit
parfois des messages d'inquiétude de la
part de ses proches
d'avoir échangé avec quelques militaires
ce centre nous annonçons prolongement
indéfini que la mission allait tenue qui
devait se terminer en 2023 on va
continuer d'être là pour défendre la
démocratie en europe et partout dans le
monde quand on lui demande s'il prêts à
aller en guerre civile a dit mir poutine
pénètre ne serait-ce qu'un centimètre à
l'intérieur d'un pays de l'otan le
premier ministre canadien est clair
l'otan et plus unis que jamais déterminé
à démontrer cette unité à tous les jours
et je peux parler pour tous les membres
de l'otan quand je dis que nous allons
tous suivent l'article 5 un article qui
stipule qu'une attaque contre un pays de
l'alliance est considéré comme une
agression contre tous les membres
le président russe veut freiner
l'expansion de le temps mais il ne fait
que la renforcer ajoute le secrétaire
général de l'organisation cet expert
prévient qu'une telle escalade très
lourde de conséquences ce serait
véritablement
des chiffres car les russes ont à leur
portée tout ce qui touche à l'arsenal
nucléaire c'est en lettonie qu'on
retrouve en ce moment le plus important
déploiement militaire canadien à
l'étranger et pour le gouvernement
trudeau qui se fait reprocher de ne pas
investir suffisamment dans le secteur de
la défense et de tarder à renouveler son
équipement militaire la visite
d'aujourd'hui est l'occasion de montrer
qu'il est tout de même un partenaire
engagé auprès de ses alliés mais si
laurence martin radio-canada à la base
militaire d'alger